[Music]
i'm looking forward to following up here
with the first two presenters and sort
of bringing in
um just a kind of some practical
extension
uh perspectives to this i also want to
thank
my original co-author and co-presenter
of the first version of this
presentation
safely utilizing animal manures and
compost
on small produce farms and its
perspective
here from montana so
you know montana is known as cattle
country we're primarily a cow-calf state
but we do have some beef back grounding
and finishing
some dairies and some hog kafos so we do
have animal production systems where
manure
is collected um
but all counties in our state do have
sufficient conventional crop ground
relative to manure nutrients uh to
to agronomically utilize those resources
while we may have some high areas of
nutrient concentration within a county
within a region of the state this can
easily be remedied
with nearby export of those manure
nutrients
so where are they going well the top
bullet points here all the common places
that
you know many of us have worked with
management planning and nutrient
management planning and whatnot so just
moving manure and manure products to
conventional crop
and forage ground a lot of our nutrients
from manure in the state get processed
compost and go to reclamation projects
so usually some sort of mining
reclamation project
could go to organic row and or forage
crops
turf and green industries you know your
sod farms and nurseries and whatnot
uh utilize a fair amount of our
exported or manure nutrients exported
from
the site of origin and then finally
sort of the new and emerging opportunity
[Music]
driven by you know interest in local
food systems
across the country but in our montana
communities as well
that opens the opportunity to move
manure to small
produce farms and market gardens
this some images here sort of
demonstrate the
the use of those manure based
products and this is at our student-run
organic farm which is actually also a
retail farm
but in this image we see the importance
of bringing
manure in manure-based compost to
renovate soils
and then also provide for ongoing
fertility
so this compost here was
mostly beef manure from a research scale
but conventional
beef feeding facility and it's being
incorporated into soil under this
movable high tunnel
and a quick comment these high tunnels
are really important to us for vegetable
production
in montana uh you see this one day here
where they're working in the area and
then the image on the right
we see snow piled up from a late spring
snow storm so
these high tunnels make small veg small
scale vegetable production
possible in montana uh
we have noticed um social barriers
related to the exchange of nutrients
from the
animal ag industry to market gardens
um and that represents you know missed
market opportunities for
moving manure nutrients into another
sector or
helping better balance local
nutrient balance and such
and we're hoping to solve this just
through more facilitation and education
both by
extension and government agencies and a
lot of the
concern or the social barriers you know
it's just based around
well the important concern over food
safety
perhaps concern over herbicide residues
passing through the manure and the
compost
and then concerns over implications for
organic certification
and real quick i want to point out a
case study about a pretty interesting
unconventional
farm a mafia organic dairy primarily
raises dairy goats
and then they have their own cheese
plant
but in all of their waste management
cycles and whatnot they also have
other enterprises they have some
pastured pork and they have an organic
vegetable
enterprise so they manufacture
compost and it's mostly used for their
on-site
animal feed crops and that's a bunch of
organically certified
uh crop feed crop ground
they also use the the compost back into
their organic
vegetable enterprise and then they also
sometimes engage in occasional compost
sales
but they are moving these nutrients
through multiple enterprises on their
farm
everything is certified organic in this
case
and then the image shows some of their
compost working areas so the most raw
stuff here is in the foreground and
these uh bigger windrows
there's some curing piles and windrows
back here
a finishing screen and then there's
another storage
area not in that image where the
finished compost
is stored separate from all of the
raw and manure and compost working areas
um we've mentioned already the previous
two speakers brought forth
uh fisma and uh
don't need to speak too much about it
now or again i should say but just to
remind everybody that it does
focus on prevention of food safety
issues and though the rules are supposed
to be science and risk based
as we've heard just recently we
recognize that additional research
can provide further guidance and
understanding of the risks involved
and then potential policy adaptations
so on the practical advice side this is
what andrea
my colleague at montana department of
agriculture and the produce safety
program she likes to call it her musts
and shoulds lists
all right and this is really pulled from
the different rules and recommendations
but
um an operation a produce operation
under fisma must know must store and
convey manure and compost so that they
do not
impact or interact with
the produce covered by the rule food
contact surfaces and
processing areas areas
used for any other fisma or produce
safety rule covered activities
should not interfere with or interact
with water sources and water
distribution
systems you know we heard earlier how
irrigation water can be a potential
conduit for pathogens from manure
to produce and then any other soil
amendments you don't want the
raw manure or unfinished compost
products to
interact with or possibly contaminate
other soil amendments
should practices this is getting down
into little more details about how you
might accomplish those musts so you
should keep raw manure and finished
compost in separate areas
like i explained previously with the a
mafia dairy example
they have three different compost and
soil amendment working in storage
areas so you have that that gap in that
distance
you should designate specific equipment
and tools for dealing with soil
amendments
and uh you know raw versus treated
and then when you must have or need to
have shared equipment
then you should have a cleaning and
sanitation program
when that equipment moves from dealing
with a raw
type soil amendment to another purpose
on the farm
particularly anything that would be
closer contact with the actual produce
more should steps to prevent this
cross-contamination at the you know
small
farm level or any farm really
limit access and traffic around all the
soil amendment areas
that includes humans farm animals
nuisance animals and scavengers
equipment
any any sort of traffic or movement
around the farm you want to be
storing uh these place these materials
in such a way that uh regular traffic is
not going to cause
cross-contamination um and then just
like we would
manage manure and compost storage on any
size
operation you want to use best
management practices
um for pollution prevention around these
storage areas as well so appropriate
storm water management
runoff or leachate capture and
management if necessary
and these would all be you know best
management practices appropriate to the
climate
environment and other state and local
rules
usda good agricultural practice
standards also
overlap along with these
woods or shoulds shoulds and musts
that we talked about from fisma and some
of this is very similar once again
so looking at treated over non-treated
[Music]
soil amendments of manure origin
the right application timing and
considering the extending those harvest
intervals
that were discussed the 9120
the application method handling and
storage
we spoke about that just two slides ago
in more detail and then record keeping
about
the management of manure compost
composting processes
and all of the soil amendments used
as far as organic certification
there's some other you know best
practices or due diligence
we've already discussed 9120
with crops contacting the ground and
crops that may be above the ground
but also the issue that we've dealt with
a lot here in montana
as manures from animal agriculture have
moved into this small
produce sector um is the issue
of ag chemical residues in that manure
compost
and so this is just going to come down
to producer due diligence to make sure
that those types of residues are not
going to impact their production
[Music]
and then as always when we're talking
about an organically certified operation
you know you should work with an expert
certifier
as you communicate with farmers and make
sure anything they're
doing or adding is okay on the nop
list of approved products
so there are a variety of players here
in montana that are working with
producers
with the produce safety rule in the
national organic program that's really
led
in the state by montana department of
agriculture we have a state
certification program
there are other organic certifiers in
the state
but they play a large role in assisting
producers
and maintaining their certifications
while using
the types of products we're learning
about today
as far as regulatory education that also
happens from our montana department of
agriculture
as well as extension both in agriculture
and in foods and nutrition
and then trade organizations as well are
important conduits for education on this
topic to our growers
and then as far as just good
agricultural practices
and all around best management practices
a lot of the same folks are involved
there but also some of our producer
co-ops
are involved in educating producers
and helping manage all of this for
growers that may be a member of say this
example
co-op so in summary
manure and compost are valuable nutrient
inputs for small produce farms
they are not generally prohibited but we
rely on best practices
and rules to reduce the risk of some
sort of contamination
and a foodborne illness
and that just comes down to proper
management as discussed
today and in general everything we
talked about here the best practices and
um
you know these rules it focuses on
preventive measures
over widespread sampling and testing of
the food products
so this is an upfront preventive
management
you know set of recommendations and
programs that we've discussed here today
um instead of you know actual widespread
sampling and testing of
all the produce produced
you